llegó el momento de revisar la prensa
internacional con Marta Moya Marta
bienvenida buena mañana de martes y
abrimos entonces nuestra sección de
revista de prensa del día de hoy
comentando con un tema que probablemente
va a abrir muchos de los titulares de la
prensa internacional los próximos días
Por qué como veníamos comentando Marta
nuestros noticieros Este martes Así es
decir el día de hoy se da comienzo
entonces a esta asamblea general de
Naciones Unidas número 77 un evento que
con que congrega mandatarios de
absolutamente todo el mundo para por
nosotros realmente los temas más
importantes de la agenda de la guerra en
Ucrania el cambio climático entre otros
Marta así a Raúl buenos días Pues
analizamos un artículo muy crítico que
publica el medio estadounidense político
un artículo Que firma Ryan hit y titula
la asamblea general de la ONU está
muerta son los espectáculos secundarios
los que realmente importan dice pues que
al final la asamblea de la ONU se ha
convertido en una especie de chocolate
donde los líderes mundiales van a verse
y a ser vistos y que si se preocuparan
realmente por los asuntos que preocupan
a la ciudadanía Pues el mundo iría mucho
mejor destaca este análisis Eso sí pues
que aunque las últimas décadas la
reducción de la pobreza o temas como la
salud pues sí que han ido adquiriendo
mayor peso y se han logrado avances en
los últimos años Pues los países se han
quedado relegados en este objetivo de
cumplir con los 17 objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible acordados en 2015
dice Cuál es el punto de que 150 jefes
de estado se reúnan en esta asamblea si
no es para adoptar este tipo de medidas
este análisis además sostiene que lo que
alguna vez fue una oportunidad para que
los líderes pronuncien discursos en un
palco mundial ahora es una versión de
davos de fin de semana pero más grande
en referencia pues a esta ciudad Suiza
donde se realiza el foro económico
mundial dice que que la asamblea se ha
convertido en un davos con esteroides y
dice que en esta ocasión además va a
estar a la sombra del funeral de Isabel
II y con los líderes más polémicos
ausentes como Vladimir Putin
precisamente Marta vamos a seguir con
este gran tema de los Últimos Días como
también lo estaba comentando en esa
última parte del Análisis del medio
político y fue que ya sé yo concluido
entonces este funeral de la Reina Isabel
segunda toda la prensa nacional
internacional recoge las portadas ese
último adiós no que le dieron pues el
mandatarios de todo el mundo su familia
y la ciudadanía en general empezamos con
the Guardian Marta Así es las portadas
son monográficas en la prensa británica
por supuesto y en la prensa
internacional de Guardian destaca en su
portada La despedida final con esta foto
del féretro de Isabel II entrando al
castillo de Windsor donde después O sea
donde se realizó Perdón este último
impacto religioso dice la insuperable
pompa y el espectáculo público diera un
paso a la intimidad con la que la
familia de la reina la llevó al descanso
no en este entierro Pues que solo al que
solo estuvo presente la familia donde Sí
además bien afectado No el Rey Carlos a
tercero con los ojos llorosos vamos
ahora con detalles también publica una
portada a todo color con este funeral de
la reina y dice llevada a su descanso
scotlán este periódico de Escocia dice
volveremos a encontrarnos con este
titular muy solemne y dice un apropiado
a Dios puso punto y final a la era
isabelina y revisamos también elíso
también en este sentido del final de La
era de la reina dice el final de La Era
isabelina una gran procesión paralizó a
Londres con un espectacular despliegue
militar Y se ve pues la imagen de la
reina en esta procesión hacia el
castillo de Windsor eso dentro Reino
Unido vamos con la prensa internacional
como lo titula New York Times y como
decíamos la prensa internacional también
apuesta en sus portadas impresas por
este último adiós a Isabel II el New
York Times dice con tristeza e
incertidumbre los británicos cerraron la
era de Isabel II estampa de Italia la
estampa dice el adiós del mundo a Su
Majestad así unió Isabel II a su pueblo
pues En referencia a estas largas colas
para despedir a la monarca que sean
bueno que han tenido lugar en estos
últimos días el estado de Sao Paulo en
Brasil Marta adiós a la reina capítulo
final de una era de realeza británica y
la nación en Argentina la nación titula
una multitud conmovida y una despedida
Monumental La despedida que paralizó al
país y reunió como decías a líderes y
miembros de la realeza de todo el mundo
para concluir Marta como despidió ayer
la bbc la cadena pública británica esta
programación especial sobre los actos
fúnebres de Isabel II la cadena pública
pues ha estado al mando de toda
programación especial fue la encargada
de anunciar en televisión el deceso de
la monarca y también pues fue ayer la
encargada de poner este punto y final a
los actos de homenaje a la monarca ayer
pues Cristian la presentadora de la bbc
despedía a Su Majestad y pues cerraba
estos 11 días de actos veamos
desde muy joven dijo la célebrecita de
que toda su vida así fuera larga o corta
estaría dedicada de botamente al
servicio de la nación bien nunca fue una
persona en la que dudar
y Hoy estamos aquí juntos muchos con
lágrimas en los ojos pero todos con el
corazón reconfortado por todo lo que nos
dio solamente hace tres meses el mundo
dijo gracias por todo durante su jubileo
de platino y la reina seguro disfrutó de
aquel momento
siempre estaremos agradecidos por haber
tenido esa oportunidad final de celebrar
con Su Majestad su destacado largo
reinado Ella dijo una vez la pena es el
precio que pagamos por el amor y este
Lamento colectivo es la muestra de
nuestro profundo afecto y su historia
fue historia la Reina Isabel segunda se
ha ido pero desde luego nunca será
olvidada
Marta Gracias por toda la información
mañana Por supuesto más revista de
prensa mañana más Raúl Muchas gracias
así es gracias a ti Marta